[Applause]
thousands of retired men and women stand
at the gates of wuhan's Junction Park
they're demonstrating against changes to
their province's health insurance policy
facing off with police one man chanted
down with the reactionary government
others sang a communist protest song The
International starting this month people
here will receive about 25 Less in
medical benefits each month
that's a significant blow to those
already struggling to get by
finally our citizens have woken up says
the man filming this video it's the
second protest to take place in Wuhan
this week
under a new pilot program the government
is diverting funds from personal
accounts to subsidize a wider range of
Hospital treatments
this Central Chinese city was the
epicenter of the coronavirus outbreak in
December 2019. in 2020 the 11 million
people living here were confined to
their homes under Beijing strict zero
covert policy
almost three years of mass testing and
quarantine has depleted local government
budgets China is also Under Pressure to
shore up the Health Care system for its
rapidly aging population
we have a shrinking population active
working population that is trying to
support this massive over 65 population
and local governments are heavily in
debt they have been
um coveted as one part of it but there
are many other parts to it too and so
local governments are scrambling to try
to understand how to
sustainably move forward
this ratio of public Defiance comes
months after historic Nationwide
protests that preceded Beijing ending
its zero curved measures internet senses
have deleted videos like these from
Chinese social media and state media has
called on people to be patient while
they adapt to the new policy these
protests are being held weeks before
China's top officials gather for the
most important political meeting of the
year the national people's Congress a
new leadership team will be unveiled
under President Xi Jinping and the
government is under pressure to calm any
public discontent over its Health
policies Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing